let's go to the next topic here with uh
president biden on what happened with
the press conference did you watch the
press conference did you no and wasn't
it two days ago two days ago yes daniel
were you able to watch it i watched some
of it
i did watch some of it the highlights
yes okay well then let me read a little
bit of it and then you you guys tell me
if you caught any of it oh i've got a
really special part of it that i want
tyler to pull perfect so biden's press
conference was an utter disaster says
new york post if president minus press
conference once it was supposed to
inspire confidence it failed horribly
even though he spent most of it clearly
calling on reporters from a list of safe
questionnaire provided by his staff he
stumbled and bumbled and all too often
made no sense at all plus he repeated
his bizarre whisper shout gimmick to
emphasize certain points
when what it actually emphasized is his
age his answers on ukraine were
particularly confused the issue is
pretty straightforward vladimir putin is
in a threatening invasion
and will do it if he thinks he can get
away with it at the least he'll try to
get the west to bribe him by promising
him much of what he wants without any
fighting
then two he ought to say putin would win
i'll bite at a heavy price the cost of
going into ukraine is a terms of
physical loss of life for the russians
they'll be able to prevail over time but
it's going to be heavy anyways there was
a bunch of different things that was
discussed his own state department
during the press conference was sending
out clarifications to what he was saying
because he was contradicting
the state department's plans that were
public
and
his own state department was like oh
sorry he just made a boo-boo yeah they
asked us so you know he just said that
uh he believes there's going to be
meddling in the midterms for elections
and zach is like well no that's not what
he said what he was trying to say no no
his words yeah he said there's going to
be meddling in 2022 midterm elections
that's not what he meant and then
kamala harris was pushed on it as well
she got really upset
and even morning joe your guy came out
and said uh putin and ji see this and
they see biden as weak they don't seem
as a strong
leader of a country but what was your
biggest takeaway watching the uh the
press uh conference um
look if this article was written by the
washington post or um something on cnn i
think it would have a lot more credence
and i understand that that the um i hate
bloomberg was reporting the same kinds
of i mean even the liberal media has
gotten pushed to the point where they're
like they've got to recognize some of
these gaffes yeah there's no doubt that
the guy is sort of a stumbling bumbling
you know gaff machine but then again so
was donald trump and that's why biden
was elected just biden was elected not
because he was going to be some super
human
uh hero to transform america it was
because he was not donald trump what
what's a whisper shout when he's like
hey listen john stossel you come at me
buddy going to try i'm going to
challenge you to a push-up contest buddy
that's a whisper yeah and i'm yelling on
the inside
stossel and you were playing volleyball
buddy
um
that's a whisper shot
thank you okay
i also think that
the media
biden doesn't do much to
um
get a lot of media attention like trump
did so the one thing that they will get
the media attention is look at him he's
an old stumbling bumbling fool oh okay
cool they'll get some clicks i mean you
worked in media forever but pat i
actually want to get your thoughts on
this one comment that he made because he
was talking about basically he's touting
his infrastructure and basically no
surprise medical bills and he basically
said the words we're not going back to
lockdowns we're not going back to school
closings um he said these words
hey look man i'm a capitalist but
sometimes
but capitalism without competition is
not capitalism it's exploitation
so
the fact that that joe biden came out
and basically called himself a
capitalist stop i think that's oh so
what stop why am i stopping no no no
like what i mean is stop you know you
because you know i can i can be
400 pounds and tell you cheesecake's not
good for you
you know you should stop eating
cheesecake
what provoked him to say that what was
the question
that was part of his speech i didn't see
him answering any questions he's being
attacked by first of all by the middle
of his party for trying to promote
socialism yeah yeah like the fact that
he even
came out and said that you've got to
applaud him for saying look i'm a
capitalist but even capitalism has some
issues well then why don't you try and
back some capitalist policies hey
i agree first of all listen let me
simplify something for you okay the
other day we showed the steve harvey
deal right what a steve harvey show
steve harvey showed uh uh
that uh the difference between the
reason why dave chappelle can get away
with anything is because he's got what
subscription description he says not
sponsors when you're sponsors you can't
say everything right okay
is is biden a subscription model or a
sponsorship model sponsorship okay then
he's not gonna say what he's saying
behind closed doors he's going to say
pfizer don't worry about it but i just
have to say that so i can get the
people's confidence but we got you i
still need your 48 million dollars on my
campaign don't worry about it so
subscription model on who became a
president or who had a shot at becoming
the president is the following names
just so you know not sponsorship whether
you like this or not sanders was a
subscription model obama's first term
was a subscription model trump's first
term was a subscription model so don't
give me this [ __ ] about aoc yeah aoc
is a subscription model this ain't about
left or right this is why i respect
sanders because he's a subscription
model okay that's a very good this guy
is not a subscription model this guy is
a sponsorship model that has to say
whatever the money people tell them
behind closed doors and that's most of
the presidents we've had in the last few
days most politicians to be honest yeah
but this is why people liked obama and
they wanted trump and they wanted
sanders that's a subscription it
couldn't be bought
this guy's this is not about policies
this is just telling you 510 20 40 88 of
our donors are five dollar donor 88 you
know those statistics that they say yeah
these guys cannot say that you remember
that one time who was a person that was
being interviewed uh oh you know what it
was it was tucker had jim jordan on
and i don't know was jim jordan who was
actually i do think it was jim jordan
when tucker said hey can you all this
stuff that you say about google and all
these other guys can you explain to us
why you took a majority or contribution
is coming from silicon valley
i don't know if you remember that or not
it was jim jordan
i thought it was jim i'd like to verify
this i don't want to put his name out
there and
defame his character if you can verify
that but the point is the moment you go
that route okay and you take money from
silicon valley you can't sit there and
say this censorship [ __ ] that
they're doing yes facebook i'll take
your hundred thousand dollars but this
sucks stop it stop it you're acting on
what you're doing yeah i said it right
it was is it who is that is it jim
jordan i was right how long ago was that
by the way can you pull that up and see
a year ago yeah a year ago i remember
that so that to me the moment that and
i'm a jim jordan guy i'm like wait a
minute
you're taking money from these guys get
your bashing censorship so that's what i
mean by stop it you know
i may be wrong no i think it's a valid
point i like the analogy that you did
with the subscription versus um
sponsorship these are a lot of
sponsorship presidents we got here
please john
i disagree that they're doing it for the
money i think the main motivator is
what will people like what will make me
popular
what will not piss people off
the money is secondary
uh okay i disagree here's why
you do that on camera you're right
you're absolutely right on camera for
sure one million percent you're right
but camera is hollywood behind closed
doors sitting down doing deals that's
real life all right but we were talking
about this in the context of the news
conference sure i get that but he was
explaining it from a standpoint of
saying what do you think about the fact
that he said this i'm a capitalist
but at the same time you know sometimes
capitalists without competition is
exploitation you're right so every time
you raise minimum wage who in the behind
closed doors goes like this amazon says
do it again
walmart says do it again we don't pay
anybody 15 bucks an hour this people
just want to trash us do it again but
the small guy that's sitting there
running a restaurant says
dude i have no clue how the hell am i
supposed to pay this waitress from 7 25
to 15 bucks an hour and tips and
restaurant my burgers are going to go
from eight dollars to nineteen dollars i
can't afford to do that yeah big
businesses love it when they raise
minimum wage so yeah that's what i mean
by exploitation these are the guys
politicians are the guys with their
policies that eliminate competition
if you leave people alone competition
will typically take care of itself minus
the monopoly side which is kind of
happening i think we would have
discovered this by now that people would
understand look at hong kong
they went from third world to first
world
because the government left them alone
and people were free to compete
flat tax
and the british rulers sat around and
drank tea
left people
to pursue their own affairs and that
took them from poor to our level of
prosperity our level of prosperity today
or back then
oh i'm talking 10 you know now china's
wrecking it but it
sorry
my my former employer is about to pull
the plug on this thing so the federal
reserve
about to pull the plug on
on liquidity on
on what makes markets go hmm
and stay happy
what
january the first they they increased
the the
reduction of purchases into the market
they doubled it so now they're
45 billion less that they're that
they're they're reversing the
quantitative easing exactly and they'll
be finished by mid-march and it's fully
anticipated
so much political
biden at his press conference said it
it's time for the fed to take care of
inflation not mine you know it's not not
not our worry that's the fed's purview
but your tone of voice says you like the
quantitative easing this is no help me
no
no you don't know
that's ddb right there no i wrote a book
called fed up why the federal reserve
was bad for america after working there
for nine years no no no
no but it's i mean it's hysterical that
the buying administration is placing all
of the blame on the supply chain
disruption i mean there's there i mean
you can't even make this stuff up so if
you enjoyed this little short segment
from the podcast that we did here's
another short segment to watch or if you
want to see the entire podcast click
over here take care everybody bye
[Music]